bonsoir ses fans et gagner merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur rt france on
sait que strasbourg est une ville qui
est touchée de manière durable ça fait
déjà quelques temps qu'il est la
situation au chu la situation chu n'est
pas trop tendue on n'est pas du tout à
saturation
on avait été très très touché par la
première vague en mars avril
mais là pour la deuxième vague ça se
passe plutôt mieux on est on est chargé
bien sûr il y a il ya beaucoup de
malades mais ça n'est pas tendu c'est
nous sommes pas du tout à saturation
c'est une information intéressante quand
on voit le nombre de cas qui augmente
désespérément malgré un le confinement
nathan le point presse on le disait un
an ce reportage de jean castex demain
vous en tant qu infectiologues
qu'est ce que vous souhaiteriez de la
part du gouvernement qu'est ce que vous
en attendez on est partagés parce que
bien sûr tout le monde a envie que cette
deuxième vague redescendre au plus vite
et là ce que l'on constate c'est que
alors qu'elle avait commencé à bien
décroître depuis quelques jours et la
décroissance s'amortit l est on a une
petite diminution du nombre de patients
nouvellement hospitalisés chaque jour on
en est à peu près sur le front national
à 12 cents patients hospitalisés chaque
jour sur le plan d admission en
réanimation
ça c'est plutôt calme sur le plan
national 200 nouvelle admission en
réanimation
environ 300 décès par jour mais on voit
en effet que hélas l'épidémie stagne un
petit peu depuis quelques jours alors
qu'on espérait que la deuxième vague
allait décroître beaucoup plus
rapidement comme l'avait fait la
première vous mais on n'est pas fâchés
voyez vous vous l'expliquez comment
docteur la faute aux français comme l'a
dit olivier ferrand pas que évidemment
il a aussi cité le froid mais mais
est-ce que c'est notre faute on s'est
mal conduit nous des français c'est il
ya plusieurs facteurs qui interviennent
en fait le froid habituellement ce que
l'on sait c'est que peu plus fait froid
et plus le virus circule parce que plus
il fait froid et plus l'arrêt sec et ça
favorise la diffusion du virus sa
transmission interhumaine le
comportement des français de toute
évidence ce deuxième confinement n'a pas
du tout été aussi rigoureux que le
premier et c'est un site c'est un
confinement qui est un petit peu allégés
et de ce que je peux en voir
à strasbourg on n'a pas du tout la même
impression que lors du premier
confinement alors que pour le premier
confinement on avait l'impression d'une
ville morte pratiquement la nasa n'est
pas le cas et on a un peu l'impression
que les gens continuent à vaquer à leurs
occupations un peu comme comme
d'habitude et donc le virus circule
c'est évident le virus circule est ce
que je ce que je remarque aussi c'est
que les gens fassent et c'est mon
impression c'est ce que j'ai constaté
que les gens quand ils quand ils se
savent observés par exemple dans la rue
dans les locaux accueillant du public
vont ils mettre leurs masques mais dès
l'instant où ils se retrouvent dans des
locaux privés des centres de formation
et cetera là et surtout avec les gens de
25 à 35 40 ans le masque à tendance être
abandonné il est certain que la
discipline n'est pas est loin d'être
parfaite
je ne dirais pas que c'est la faute des
français mais la discipline loin d'être
parfaite et le virus circule évidemment
alors de l'autre côté de la manche on a
débuté la vaccination en france il
faudra un petit peu patienter en tout
cas ça sera pour le début de l'année
dans le meilleur des cas vous ferez
partie vous les soignants des premiers
vaccinés quelle est votre position que
l'état d'esprit par rapport aux débats
actuels
bon de toute façon il faut être lucide
cette épidémie cette pandémie ne pourra
s'éteindre complètement que dans 2 deux
cas de figure possibles soit on a
atteint un taux d'immunité collective
immunité de groupe spontanée par la
simple circulation du virus et on en est
encore loin
je ne pensais pas qu'il y aurait une
forte deuxième bague parce que j'avais
tendance à surestimer le taux d'immunité
collective mais là manifestement étant
donné la reprise épidémique
on se rend compte que le taux d'immunité
collective reste assez faible
c'est à dire qu'il est sans doute aux
alentours de 25 30% et le compte n'y est
pas parce que pour qu'une épidémie
s'éteignent il faut un taux d'immunité
collective au moins de 60% voire 70% et
la deuxième possibilité c'est la
vaccination
il n'ya que ces deux possibilités alors
la vaccination ont bien sûr ces
discussions vont bon train parce que les
français ne sont pas très favorables aux
vaccins d'une façon générale disent ils
ils sont méfiants et puis on sait très
bien qu'avec les vaccins c'est il ya une
compétition infernal d'entre les
différents laboratoires
s'il a conclu la compétition est féroce
et on sourit on sait très bien que les
temps de développement des vaccins ont
été raccourcis au maximum on le donne
des taux d'efficacité
alors autant tôt 95 97 70 % et ses taux
d'efficacité les docteurs ça vous
inquiète justement auditeurs là on a
accéléré les choses c'est vrai que là le
canada vient de donner aujourd'hui ce
soir son feu vert au vaccin de pfizer
biotech tout comme le royaume uni c'est
le même ça va trop vite de manière
anormale
ça va trop vite par rapport à la
situation habituelle dans laquelle on
met au point un vaccin
la plupart des vaccins sont mis au point
pour des maladies chroniques subaiguë
mais pas pas des épidémies comme ça sert
à vous pourrez bola on l'a fait aussi
mais le contexte n'était pas le même
donc on est pressé par le temps étant
donné que cette épidémie continue et
forcément on est obligé d'aller plus
vite
alors ça ne veut pas dire que l'on
respecte pas les règles de sécurité
mais les essais ne sont pas terminés et
d'ailleurs un afficheur l'a dit dans sa
conférence hier il ya quelques jours il
a dit il ya encore beaucoup d'inconnues
avec ces vaccins
il s'est évertuée à rassurer les
français en disant des inconnus ne
concerne pas tellement les effets
indésirables mais l'efficacité
il a dit qu'on ne connaissait pas
exactement le taux le taux d'efficacité
cgt pourcentage que l'on donne
ils sont un peu approximatif il doit
encore évoluer et puis il a dit qu'on ne
savait pas si le vaccin à les protéger
de la contamination c'est à dire rendre
les personnes vaccinées non contagieuse
il a dit qu'il était réservé aussi quant
à l'atténuation de la gravité des signes
des symptômes et dessine chez les
personnes vaccinées
donc il ya encore beaucoup d'inconnues
merci merci beaucoup d'inconnues ça sera
le le dernier mot
merci stéphane caillet affectionne au
chu de strasbourg d'avoir été en direct
avec nous sur rt france hommes